ما دلالات عوده عمليات المقاومه الى مناطق
الشمال وبهذه
القوه يعني اولا حينما انسحب الجيش
الاسرائيلي لم ينسحب لانه انجز مهمته هذا
حينما كذب على على جيشه وعلى جبهته
الداخليه وقال انجزنا المهمه لذلك انسحبنا
هذا يؤكد بان ضراوه المقاومه
والاشتباكات مع الجيش الاسرائيلي والخسائر
التي مني بها الجيش الاسرائيلي في الشمال
هي الت التي اجبرته على الانسحاب ومعروف
ان المقاومه
الفلسطينيه يعني تعمل وفق قواعد الفدائيين
بمعنى حينما ينسحب العدو الاسرائيلي من
الاماكن التي وصل اليها
تتقدم المقاومه و حينما يتراجع العدو ايضا
تلحقه وتشتبك معه وهو في حاله الانسحاب
وحينما يعود ت يعني تعطيه تعطيه امكانيه
ال العوده في البدايه ومن ثم تنصب له
الكمائن وتشتبك معه كما يجري الان في ارض
في شمال قطاع غزه انا اعتقد انه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه والمقاومين ما زالوا يسيطرون
على الميدان رغم ان الجيش الاسرائيلي
يحاول التمدد مره ثانيه ولكن في ظل اسناد
جوي وفي ظل اسناد مدفعي وهذا ما يبطئ
حركتهم على الارض وما يعطي فرصه للمقاومين
الفلسطينيين على نصب الك والاشتباك معهم
في من حيث لا يعلمون وخاصه ان هناك انفاق
وهناك ايضا مناطق تم تدميرها خاصه الابنيه
التي اصبحت ركام فبالتالي هذا الركام اصبح
بمثابه خنادق للمقاومين الفلسطينيين
يستطيعون التحر فيه بسهوله المجال في هذا
المجال لواء واصف عريقات يعني بعد تقريبا
اربعه اشهر من المعارك ومن هذه الحرب
الضاريه جدا على ق قطاع غزه يتحدث
المسؤولون الاسرائيليون الان عن مصاعب
واقرار من جانب بعض العسكريين ل صحيفه
نيويورك تايمز بان شبكه الانفاق معقده
لدرجه انه لا يمكن تدميرها او القضاء
عليها ايضا ما معنى كل
ذلك يعني بالتاكيد الجيش الاسرائيلي حتى
الان لا يملك المعلومات لا عن المقاومين
الفلسطينيين ولا عن الانفاق فبالتالي ال
المقاومه فوق الارض مجهوله بالنسبه
للاسرائيليين الارض
فهذا يعني اهم اهم عنصر من عناصر القتال
في الميدان العسكري ان تعرف قدرات من
تقاتله وان تعرف امكانيات من تقاتله وان
يكون منظور لك اما في حاله المقاومين
الفلسطينيين فهم منتشرين فوق الارض ومنتشر
تحت الارض وبالتاكيد هم مجهولين بالنسبه ل
الجيش الاسرائيلي ويحاول الجيش الاسرائيلي
من خلال اعتقال اكبر عدد ممكن من ال
المدنيين الفلسطينيين وتعذيبهم حتى الموت
من اجل الحصول على المعلومات ولكن انا
بتقديري ليس كل مدني يعرف عن هذه الانفاق
وليس كل مدني يعرف عن المقاومه الفلسطينيه
والمقاومين الفلسطينيين واماكن تواجدهم
وقدراتهم القتاليه فبالتالي هذا ما يعقد
مهمه الجنود الاسرائيليين خاصه انه
الاجهزه الامنيه والاستخبار حتى الان وهذا
باعتراف الجنود والضباط الاسرائيليين
عاجزين عن تقديم المعلومات عن المقاتلين
وعن قدرات المقاتلين في الميدان وعلما
بانه الطائرات سواء كانت بريطانيه او
امريكيه وحتى الاقمار الصناعيه تعمل في
خدمه الجيش الاسرائيلي من اجل البحث عن
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وعن الانفاق وعن
الاسرى وعن القيادات الاسرائيليه ومع كل
ذلك وحتى الروبوتات يعني عملوا على
الروبوتات من اجل ان تقوم بكشف هؤلاء سواء
كان اسرى او قيادات مقاومه او مقاومين
ولكنها حتى الان فشلت في تنفيذ هذه المهمه